you know I got asked about the the
William Shatner Twitter was weirdness I
mean who loves you currently doesn't
well I heard he made up with me I mean
he sort of did it's like a total 180
well then I was just kind of watching
the fight like a fan myself you know
like I was just kind of I wasn't really
a part of it I was like oh my god
William gender knows who I am this is
amazing like that was my reaction uh I
don't and you're caught in between I
mean like he obviously was a big fan of
yours yeah you're like oh he loves me he
loves me brother why don't you love my
knee was y'all right for doing whatever
it is I may or may not have done to you
but he's clear about what it is but
anyways I'm a fan William I don't know
who's Donna to shoot when I'm gone I
don't want to think about it I want you
to love you now there was improvement
from last week sort of like stiffness
but still once again you have to breathe
when you move the definition of Foxtrot
is effortless ease that was a little bit
Skippy mixed reviews from live from the
judges but what was the difference you
feel like you maybe you could have done
better out there yeah i mean i was you
know overall happy with performances i
was overall happy with the performance I
thought the scores were fair
[Music]